Donald Trump's brain sort of weirdly
glitched again and he spoke total
nonsense yesterday to an audience at the
prescription drug abuse and heroin
summit of 2019 and we've talked about
this before and before I show you the
video that the most important thing I
want to explain is that this is
different than when George W Bush said
weird things like I'm not trying to
defend george w bush nor do i think he
deserves any defending but in this case
the comparison is sort of instructive
when Bush said something like when wings
take dream he just messed up a quote
right when Bush said fool me once shame
on you fool me you can't get fooled
again
there wasn't an indication that his
brain was glitching any more than his
sort of normal state of cognition but
with Donald Trump these very strange
glitches are starting to pile up and
much like dr. John Gartner has been
predicting when we've interviewed him on
the program they're happening more and
more frequently check this out from
yesterday we will not solve this
epidemic overnight but we will stop
there's just nothing gonna stop us no
matter how you cut it I know some of the
people in this room nothing stops you
nothing stops you I can tell you we will
never stop until our job is done and
then maybe we'll have to find something
new and I hope that's gonna be soon but
we will succeed we have results that are
unbelievable seems to be kind of a
combination of miss reading his
teleprompter and getting visibly
confused and there aren't ever really
good explanations for these and the
common thread is that you see in Trump's
expression the slight recognition that
he knows he's doing or saying something
a little bit odd but it's just beyond
his control in a way here's another
example the oranges of the investigation
and I hope that this investigation now
which is finished
it's totally finished no collusion no
obstruction I hope they now go and take
a look at the oranges or the oranges of
the investigation the beginnings
of that investigation you look at the
origin of the investigation where it
started how it started who started it
whether it's the Cape or Co me or a lot
of them where does it go how high up in
the white house did it go you will all
get Pulitzer Prizes okay you're gonna
all get Pulitzer Prizes you should have
looked at it a long time ago and that's
the only thing that's disappointing to
me about the Muller report the Muller
report
I wish covered the oranges how it
started the beginnings of the
investigation we still never really got
an explanation for that or for
god-blessed the United Sates originally
there was speculation about dentures
then Trump's medical report didn't say
anything about dentures rich dudes also
usually get dental implants not dentures
remember this one
let us rethink old assumptions and open
our hearts and minds to possible and
possibilities and finally I asked the
leaders of the region politically
religious Israeli and Palestinian Jewish
and Christian and Muslim to join us in
the noble quest for lasting peace thank
you
god bless you god bless Israel God bless
the Palestinians and god bless the
United States thank you very much and
then there are these other examples when
Trump couldn't find his limo which was
right in front of him and started
wandering off you might remember that
there is the time that he showed up in
the White House to sign an executive
order and then just walked out of the
room without even signing it look thank
you everybody you're gonna see some very
very strong results very very quickly
thank you very much thank you
Mike Pence had to pretend that they were
planning on signing it in some other
room all along and then there's that
really bizarre moment when Trump just
sort of wandered away from Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu as they were
supposed to do a handshake and a picture
and had to be called back and then maybe
most odd remember when Rudy Giuliani was
literally two feet across the table
directly in front Donald Trump closer
than this camera is to me right now and
Trump was looking around the room for
him with that I want to introduce
Giuliani and he's going to be working
with Jared Kushner and with Tom Basu
we're also here a very important thing
to him to what he does and maybe I'll
ask Rudy to say a few words we could
really do these all day there's walking
away from the argentinian president at
the g20 in argentina there is a lot of
this stuff and the theme is barely
holding it together visibly struggling
to put together a coherent thought
barely able to finish a sentence barely
able to sort of complete a some kind of
logical and sequential argument never
mind stay remotely on topic and it's not
like anything we've seen before I don't
know what to make of it I don't know
what it is we've had mental health
professionals who say it's a pre
dementia state we've gone other
explanations I don't know what to make
of it but I'm open to hearing thoughts
from you about it if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out the David Pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use
Photoshop how to edit videos they have
classes on drawing painting business
cooking nutrition personal productivity
and I'm not even really scratching the
surface I recently took a great class on
introductory watercolour painting I'm
still not good but I am learning and you
can access the entire library of fun
easy-to-use online courses for free for
two months by using the link underneath
this video two months of learning
something that's totally new to you
something you want to get better at
something you already love or you can
get ahead in your career by learning new
skills that will help you at your job
I've gotten a ton out of it Pat has
taken some courses that he's found
really valuable and I think you'll love
it to get started for free
by clicking the link under this video